si quieres construir una cultura donde los altruistas tengan éxito
es realmente tener una cultura
donde pedir ayuda es normal, donde la gente pregunta mucho.
Esto puede ser un poco incómodo para algunos.
[¿Así que en todas tus relaciones, siempre tienes que ser el altruista?]
(Risas)
Lo que se nota con los altruistas de éxito
es que reconocen que está bien recibir algo a cambio también.
Si uno dirige una organización, podemos hacer esto aún más fácil.
Podemos facilitar que la gente pida ayuda.
Junto a un par de colegas estudiamos hospitales.
Descubrimos que algunas enfermeras pedían mucha ayuda
y en otros departamentos no tanto.
Lo que destacó allí donde pedir ayuda era algo normal,
donde era la norma,
es que había una enfermera cuyo único trabajo era
ayudar a otras enfermeras de su departamento.
Cuando esa función se hizo disponible, las enfermeras se dijeron:
"No es vergonzoso ni vulnerable pedir ayuda; en realidad se fomenta".
Pedir ayuda no es importante
solo para proteger el éxito y el bienestar de los altruistas,
sino también crucial para aumentar el comportamiento altruista
porque los datos dicen que entre el 75 y el 90 %
de todos los favores entre compañeros comienza con una solicitud.
Pero mucha gente no pregunta.
No quieren parecer incompetentes,
no saben a dónde acudir, no quieren cargar a los demás.
Sin embargo, si nadie nunca pide ayuda,
tendrán un montón de altruistas frustrados en su organización
a quienes les encantaría ayudar y contribuir,
solo con saber a quién podrían ayudar y cómo.
Pero creo que lo más importante
si quieren construir una cultura de altruistas exitosos
es estar atentos a quién incorporan en su equipo.
Pensaba que si quieren una cultura de generosidad productiva,
deberían contratar a un montón de altruistas.
Pero me sorprendió descubrir que en realidad eso funcionaba,
que el impacto negativo de un oportunista en una cultura
es en general el doble o el triple del impacto positivo de un altruista.
Piensen en ello de esta manera:
una manzana podrida pudre todo el cesto
pero una golondrina no hace un verano.
No sé qué significa eso...
(Risas)
pero espero que lo hagan; mejor no, dejen un oportunista en el equipo
y verán que los altruistas dejarán de ayudar.
Dirán: "Esto es un nido de víboras. ¿Por qué debo contribuir?"
Pero si dejan un altruista en el equipo, no habrá una explosión de generosidad,
sino más bien, la gente dirá:
"Genial, esa persona puede hacer todo nuestro trabajo".
Por lo tanto, en la contratación efectiva, la selección y creación de un equipo
no se trata de traer a los altruistas sino de eliminar a los oportunistas.
Si lo hacen bien, solo tendrán altruistas y compañeros.
Los altruistas serán generosos
porque no tienen que preocuparse de las consecuencias.
Y el encanto de los compañeros es que siguen la norma.
Entonces, ¿cómo se descubre al oportunista antes de que sea demasiado tarde?
En realidad nos cuesta identificar a los oportunistas
especialmente a primera vista.
Hay un rasgo de su personalidad que nos despista: la amabilidad;
un rasgo principal de personalidad a través de culturas.
Las personas agradables son cálidas y amistosas, son agradables, son educadas.
Muchos de ellos se encuentran en Canadá...
(Risas)
donde hubo realmente un concurso nacional
para proponer un nuevo eslogan canadiense y rellenar el espacio en blanco,
"Tan canadiense como..."
Pensé que la ganadora iba a ser:
"Tan canadiense como el jarabe de arce", o, "como el hockey sobre hielo".
Pero no, los canadienses votaron por un nuevo lema nacional
-- y no les tomo el pelo --
"Tan canadiense como sea posible bajo las circunstancias".
(Risas)
Ahora, los que son muy agradables, o tal vez un poco canadienses,
lo entienden de inmediato.
¿Cómo podría decir que soy único
cuando estoy constantemente adaptándome tratando de complacer a otras personas?
Las personas desagradables hacen esto mucho menos a menudo.
Son más críticas, escépticas, desafiantes,
y mucho más probable que estudian derecho que sus colegas.
(Risas)
No es broma, realmente es un hecho empírico.
Así que siempre supuse que la gente agradable era altruista
y los desagradables oportunistas.
Pero luego reuní los datos
y me sorprendió encontrar ninguna correlación entre esos rasgos
porque parece que la dualidad amabilidad-antipatía es una capa:
¿Qué tan agradable es interactuar con Ud.?
Mientras que ser altruista o un oportunista es más bien una motivación interior:
¿Cuáles son sus valores? ¿Cuáles son sus intenciones hacia los demás?
Si realmente quieres juzgar a la gente con precisión,
hay que llegar al momento que cada consultor en la sala está esperando,
y dibujar una pequeña tabla.
(Risas)
Los altruistas agradables son fáciles de detectar:
dicen que sí a todo.
Los oportunistas desagradables también se reconocen rápidamente,
aunque se les conoce por un nombre ligeramente diferente.
(Risas)
Nos olvidamos de las otras dos combinaciones.
Hay altruistas desagradables en nuestras organizaciones.
Hay personas que parecen duras
pero en su interior, están motivados por las mejores intenciones.
O como dijo un ingeniero: "¡Los altruistas desagradables!
Unos con una mala interfaz de usuario pero un gran sistema operativo".
(Risas)
Si eso les ayuda.
Los altruistas desagradables son los más infravalorados en nuestras organizaciones,
porque son los que dan el feedback negativo
que nadie quiere oír pero todos necesitan oír.
Tenemos que valorar mucho mejor a estas personas
en lugar de tacharlos como tal de inmediato y decir:
"Es una persona un poco difícil seguro es un oportunista egoísta".
La otra combinación que olvidamos es la mortal...
oportunista agradable, también conocido como el falso.
Esta es la persona que de cara es agradable
y luego te apuñalará por la espalda.
(Risas)
Y mi manera favorita de atraparlos en el proceso de la entrevista
es hacerles la pregunta: "¿Puedes nombrar a cuatro personas
a quienes les has ayudado mucho en sus carreras?
Los oportunistas le darán cuatro nombres
y todos serán más influyentes que ellos,
porque los oportunistas saben engatusar y luego dar una patada.
Es más probable que los altruistas nombren gente menos influyente que ellos
que no tiene tanto poder,
que no puede traerles beneficio alguno.
Y seamos realistas, todos saben se puede aprender mucho sobre el carácter
viendo cómo alguien trata a un camarero o al chófer de Uber.
Así que si hacemos todo esto bien,
si podemos eliminar a los oportunistas de las organizaciones,
si creamos un entorno seguro para pedir ayuda,
si podemos proteger a los altruistas del agotamiento
y creamos un marco donde sean ambiciosos
y perseguir sus propios objetivos a la vez que ayudar a otras personas,
podemos cambiar la manera de definir el éxito.
En lugar de decir que se trata de ganar una competencia,
nos daremos cuenta de que el éxito significa más bien colaboración.
Creo que la manera más significativa de tener éxito
es ayudar a otras personas a tener éxito.
Y si podemos difundir esa creencia,
podemos realmente revertir la paranoia.
Hay un nombre para eso.
Se llama "pronoia".
Pronoia es la creencia engañosa
de que otras personas están tramando su bienestar.
(Risas)
Que están yendo detrás de tu espalda
alabándote a más no poder.
(Risas)
Lo bueno de una cultura de altruistas es que no es una ilusión,
es la realidad.
Quiero vivir en un mundo donde los altruistas tengan éxito
y espero que me ayuden a crear ese mundo.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)